歡迎回到趙華
阿倫說
好 我們台股現在啊
有所謂的第四大法人
你有聽說嗎
有 現場有一位
幹嘛直接破題
不好意思
像最近在智習亮
你會覺得主力大戶
其實沒事做
其實我覺得
因為它那個波動變比較小
或者說它延續性不好
那可能以波段來講
我覺得就會比較喜歡停看廳
但是我們這位
這一個第四大法人
可能也蠻喜歡這種上下波動
單日的那種上下波動盤
是 對
因為我們都覺得現在盤很黏
可能散戶朋友覺得無聊
大戶可能也會覺得無聊
但不是
大戶其實還滿滿
滿有聊的是不是
對 就是人家之所以會成功
有他之所以會成功的原因
我們先來歡迎他
就是我們的全鎮小哥
嗨 楊美好
好 我們今天幫小哥
取了一個綽號叫
台灣傳奇散戶
但是我覺得你已經不是散戶了
你已經是大戶了
會不會這樣子講太那個
太對付你了
對 這樣寫
有台灣兩個字都覺得很驕傲
因為最近是所謂的量比較低
6000多億的成交量
那很多人都覺得說
可能大戶都不玩了
但是我每天看小哥的臉書
IG他玩得很開心
沒錯 對
對我們而言蠻好玩的
是 這種盤也蠻好玩的
你這邊有一個slogan
精準獵殺
鎖定主力新目標
狙擊分點 隔日沖 急速獲利
你這是拍什麼電影嗎
這蠻好玩
因為我們多空都會做
例如說遇到波段做多的大戶就跟
像大立光 川湖
這個都是很厲害的大戶在買
這種就跟單
遇到隔日沖會大買的
隔天大部分都大賣
那就跟著他們一起賣就好了
所以這個多空都蠻好玩的
所以小哥每天还是很忙
很忙之余呢
也会来告诉我们
到底在这样的量里面
这样算自习量吗
还是搞不好会有其他的量更低
主力到底在忙着买什么
帮我们讲故事
好 那我们首先来讲台股的波段主力
那波段主力呢
通常都是买一段时间叫波段
像这个三多哥
三多哥代表作大力光
他在高雄嘛 对不对
凯基山多
代表作我们之前在理财团秀
也讲过蛮多次
就大力光买很多
最近大力光有点获利了解
不过卖的也不多
后面又去买川湖
每次川湖大买的那一天
就会卖大力光
你知道为什么吗
为什么
交割金不够
比较贵一点
所以大会跟我们一样
也是有交割款不够的困扰
那這個三多哥
我覺得最近算是票房的保證
票房保證 因為他大力光好像蹲蠻久的
蹲蠻久的
大概賺了也快一倍了
那川武呢 8000多買
跌到6000多想說
這次該不會吃憋了吧
所以真的很厲害
不過他們到底不知道依據的信心從何而來
因為感覺上跌下來也沒有在做停損這件事
沒有
我們散戶要停損 到叫佈局
口袋深 分批布局
散戶口袋浅了
后面没得布局直到听损
所以不太一样
但三多哥看中的
好歹是这种EPS高速成长的
高价高全值股票
还有其他的像这个永宁哥
永宁哥的波段比较短一点
他有时候两天 有时候三天
有时候就可能长一点
有时候可能到一个礼拜
像最近他抄底的被動元件
就比較長一點
他現在還抱著嗎
他現在大部分還是出了
抬一段時間他就輸掉了
那被動他抄的那個點
其實很漂亮
為什麼這麼說呢
因為他抄點跟我抄點一樣
自己貼近一下
鼓勵就在前面
其實蠻開心的
我在抄完的那一天
去看一下分店
永寧哥跟我同時燕鏡場
超誰
華西科
然後華西科連續點
因為那時候又是
儲置股又儲量
所以其實大戶看的角度
都蠻類似的
所以這個永林哥
我覺得他的交易的邏輯
還有他每次買的那個點
我覺得都很漂亮
這個也蠻值得研究的
最近的代表作是全新
對啊 這個
全新他三天4千萬就落袋了
那最近他比較短一點
像全新的比较厉害
一买完之后
可定又涨停又涨停
那这种也蛮常见的
所以他买了之后
还不一定是只有一根涨停
有可能是两根涨停
好 这个是土城永宁吗
原大土城永宁
是不是他也做过航运
有
他只要是热门的题材
他都有玩过
所以但他比较短
短一点点
短的波段
那我们以前讲说不只隔日冲
可能三日冲这样子
可能三日冲一周冲这样
好 还有一位
还有一位是康永哥
这就比较长的波段了
最经典代表作就是2016年的大宇芝
现在已经改名了
那时候买100块卖在260
等到买完之后呢
股票北上走一段
高档卖完之后呢
股票南下走一趟
所以你跟着他做
这大约260块
你可能可以赚到300块
就上面赚一段150
底下赚一段又150
多空都做的话
所以它算是很大量
而且蛮厉害的
到现在为止
它也是持续的布局股票
这些歌会找你吗
不会
你为什么都在外面讲我
也不会因为你讲换分点
也不会
所以我們都講很多年了
都沒換
有些比較短線的他會換
有些還會怎樣你知道嗎
有些你都觀察他了
然後他的波段會變格式充足
那很在乎你
對啊 這種比較害怕一點
因為你都覺得他是波段然後他買了你跟著買結果他買的隔是要到貨的那這有一些歌是這樣我就不方便在這邊講了不方便把它講出來
好 我們剛剛舉的這些例子
其實股票也有幫我們列出來
而且最重要的是
他們到底現在在幹嘛
在幹嘛 首先我們來看一下
這個大力光 它之前的位置
真的是非常低
這邊嗎 在地方
對 那個位置超低
那它第一檔大買的時候
我們就有在理財產就講
所以這個一定要留意
買完之後他還賠錢
我們那時候來說
這個大戶賠錢的時候你不賠
東山再起你是誰
結果後面真的是東山再起
2000多塊漲到5000多塊
那我們可以看一下
到5000多塊他有大賣嗎
他有賣
但是并不是出脫的那种卖
所以呢
对于大立光而言
他们的目标价不是这个价钱
他是先获利入带一些
他是获利入带拿去搅穿武
搅穿武
你看你可以看到
其实穿武大买的时候
就是在大立光大卖的时候
交割金不够
所以那穿武也蛮厉害
这个大买之后是8000多块
那前波7月份的股灾
穿武又跌
跌到6000多 他也没卖
那最近川普涨上来
他还大幅的加码
所以这档股票
对三多哥而言
应该这个价位
是没有满足他的
好 那他现在就是主要这两档高价
他就没有再去布局其他的
比较没有
三多哥还蛮专一的
对 蛮专二的
不要中二就好了
这样是两档专二的
所以大家也可以参考一下
三多个布局
零股也可以
对 他下次大买我一定跟的
因为他这两把都很漂亮
而且下跌的时候刚刚有讲
还蛮有勇气继续摊平
那这边的话是讲康永哥
对 康永哥年代比较久远一点
这以前叫大宇之
现在叫光聚晶电
对 那我们可以看到
那个图在左边
在2016年买过一波
其实他大宇之买过蛮多坡的
所以他就是大宇之的关键分店
那这几坡其实买卖点都蛮漂亮
就是都低买高卖
他还蛮密集在买卖的
对 他就买了
然后一个波段然后卖掉
那跌了又卖掉
所以这个大宇之他玩得蛮精彩的
就是当年算是一个代表座
玩到人家如果改名字
对啊 我就想说
這麼康永哥這樣買的股票
應該是蠻優秀的
講完後面改名的
那你看後面這一段空投
康永哥就賣掉了
賣光光了
所以康永哥可能看到什麼東西
他就先出脫
後面空投就沒有他了
還記得康永哥以前做過一檔統證
因為那時候我們兩個在做
歌有仇必報的時候聊的
對 趙婉好記性
統證他也是買的很多
而且統證那點也很漂亮
我們也是靠統證賺不少
這種波段的大哥
買的股票只要是低檔
他賠錢的時候
都是好買一點
因為大家都可能會覺得
會不會是你看錯
但後面就發現
他又想辦法
是你看太短
是我錢不夠
對 是人家看比較長這樣
人家看比較長
好
那最近買的是波城
波城那從低檔開始佈局
你看從10塊錢這邊
而且買蠻多的
後面在高檔在三四十塊
他也持續布局
十塊買到四十塊再買
對 到現在這個位置也沒有買
所以也不知道要看到哪邊
不過這個博城目前在一個大幅的
大帶寬的平行通道
所以各位你要買的話
買在下通道比較安全
到了上通道你就不要追了
然後上通道之後你追
那跌下來你就想說
人家康永哥都在持有著
你到底要不要賣
心裡很掙扎 很糾結
不如馬來下通道
馬來下通道你就不會有這些想法
不過康永哥的布局有時候
是相當長久 很長
他也有過很多案例是
布局很長 後面沒動
也有啦 也有 對啊
這樣聽起來我們又害怕起來
對啊 真的康永哥跟那個
山多哥比起來
這個山多哥打擊率比較高
目前是二個打席
兩隻安打
沒錯 比較厲害
就是卡永哥最近在布局博程
大家參考
那這個巨響是另外一個分別
這個也是最近網友問我的
他問我說
小哥你有沒有看到巨響有個蹲蘭哥
不是國泰蹲蘭
是另外一個蹲蘭
國泰蹲蘭據說是散戶最大宗的聚集
我今天聽到一個消息
我覺得蠻震驚的
什麼東西
聽說很多主力都改去國泰頓南
眼人耳目
對啊 因為國泰頓南
它就很多散戶
那我藏在一個很多散戶之間
大家就不知道我是主力了
所以還有用這一招
蠻厲害的
難怪現在大家覺得
散戶變聰明了是不是這個原因
有可能 其實都是主力
主力變散戶
對啊 所以這個
有時候分點
講太多也好像也不太好
有時候這個主力會躲避一下
那這巨牆呢
敦蘭格最近也是買蠻多的
那一樣
它也是一個平行的通道
平行通道呢
你就下通道再佈局就好了
你不要去追在上通道
那不過有一天只要它開布林
往上走
可能就是另一波行情在開始
現在下布林附近
對 現在是在一個震盪的過程
震盪吃貨中
那為什麼我不能買在
布林通道的下方等於減便宜
你可能下通道比較好
但是就可能要等
等抄跌
或者你可以區間操作
因為它現在這個貸寬也到2-30%了
也還可以區間操作
好 就是統一蹲南哥
也算是一個波段高速
對 它也是蠻厲害的
那這邊的話也把我們
乾脆就做了一張表
來統整最近主力大戶
可能比較鎖定的標的
後來看那個表發現
好像不是只有AI股
現在開始擴散到傳產類了因為AI股很多都漲多啦或者是有很多套勞賣押的問題那所以傳產股相對而言比較乾淨一點
籌碼比較乾淨
股價比較低一點
你看一下這幾檔
這都是主時 主五有在買的
那乖離年限
除了像這個台生科比較高以外
聯電稍微高以外
還有盟利比較高
那有的都沒有乖離年限很多
那这边有投信连买的天数
还有投信买超占成交量的%数
那像这些呢
我们喜欢主投买的股票
就是主力有在买
投信有在买
主投买的股票呢
筹码比较安定
好 当然主力这边还是既然是专访嘛
还是在帮大家讲一下
5天跟10天的筹码集中度
10以上就已经非常高了
对
这10天的筹码集中度
到10这个数字
就很不错了
好 像前幾天其實小哥也有在達人秀講說
現在航運
其實抽碼集中度超級高
說40 50
這非常誇張
所以這個抽碼集中度呢
我們就這樣子看
好 那我們來看一下這幾檔
神達
來了一檔最沒風浪的
就是神達
沒有風浪
他根本就一條直線躺在地上
對啊 像這種就是主力緩慢吃貨重
你看主力有買外資有買
投信前陣子有買
這看起來是調整的買盤
那主力最近有買
所以我覺得這種緩慢吃貨中
然後殖利率也還漂亮的股票
像這種就是一個逢低布局的好機會
可是這個就不會太無聊嗎
會有點無聊
因為你看看他貸寬
他貸寬非常的窄
隨時要表態的意思
貸寬很窄
貸寬很窄就是平常政府都很小
那有個方法就是
你就買個零股
買個零股也才90塊
然後放在自選
假如有一天你看它漲8%
進去
因為漲8%就是發動了
就發動了
那時候就把一股換成一張這樣
不要因為漲了那8%
覺得錯過什麼
那本來是發動的訊號
對 發動訊號
因為它吃這麼久
會有一天發動
好 這個是
雖然躺很久
很多朋友覺得它很牛
但是搞不好一發動
就不可收拾
是啊
現在看這2464的蒙利
萌利这个是有在动的
它这波动度已经上升了
那有在动
你看从118到208
一下也涨了一倍
涨了一倍之后的回挡
然后月线往上升
这边回挡到上升月线
是个好卖点
这是其一
那第二呢
我们就要看这个
主力在回挡的时候有没有大卖
那主力在回挡的时候没有大卖
没有大卖的月线就确认是个好卖点
有创过历史新高又下来
那主力又沒有走
沒有走 對
而且這種下來
只要只下來一次就彈了
就是好的買點
假如下來一次
又下來一次就不要買了
下來太多次了
如果沒有主力的那個財力
就先不要買了
對 就不要買
好 現在下一個
下一個遠東銀
遠東銀最近的籌碼
你看一路的往上
所以看起來不錯
而且算是低價的銀行股
籌碼也蠻頂的
最近主力有在买
因为富邦建营创下挂牌以来的新高
所以这种小型的银行股搞不好会跟
对
不要小看金融股
母鸡带小鸡
对
好 下一个
新复发
怎么可能 银件
银件我们觉得怎么可能
房市好像也没回温
对 可是它最近有点开布林的样子
开布林
是不是因为高股息
有可能 它值率真的蛮高的
它有点开布林
然後主力買開布林
不過新富財還真的是牛
即便他開布林
也是開得很牛皮的樣子
那邊開布林可能一次都
3% 5% 他開布林可能就1% 2%這樣
這樣開是不是
也是開啦 緩慢的開
那主力最近也是有買
接下來寶瑞
遮了一身
因為每次小哥說寶瑞
我就會說寶瑞就不會動啊
不會動喔
生技股裡面以前是股王
現在你看藥药要操作到什麼程度了
小哥就說動啊
動了 創高了
你看今天473了
怎麼473
印象裡面是800塊的股票
我那時候講是比較低檔
3 400的時候
也是
然後最近也是緩慢的
這個動上來
這個沒有動很快
但慢慢的也創高
到底有沒有
因為寶瑞的話
我們說是這個
由藥品代工的網
織網 台積電
藥品類的台積電
可是真的是一蹶不振
就是股價很溫吞
不過創高就是好事情
因為創高代表上面的賣壓比較少
那最近主力有買
投信前兩天突然大買
真的耶 買上天
對啊 那投信買股票
也不是隨便能買的
已經有做過研究了
那他又是主力買投信買
又有波段權證
所以看起來應該是不錯
因為我實在印象很深
權證是有時間價值的
可是有一個權證大戶
就非常愛他
就一直壓住在他身上
好
所以看起來可能有機會
機會看來
因為投信也跑來了
符合主投賣
好 那這邊的話
小哥每天為什麼很忙
是因為他
偶爾也會看看這些可日衝
跟著做所謂的
極速獲利攻略
這邊有想要做短線的朋友
想學的
因為我們都教大家做廠
死豹
可是應該也會有人
想要做短線一點的
小哥來教學
好 那我們可以這樣講
你做股票
很多人做個都做錯了
他早上一開盤
他會想買股票
到了尾盤之後呢
他就在想說
我今天到底是要
來做當沖
還是要做股東
通常都是有賺做當沖
沒賺做股東
然後漸漸的就成為很多
加工資的股東
就變成蠱蠱蠱
蠱蠱就一堆
怎麼都是賠錢的
那就是他做錯方向
其實一早
一早其实是要找时间卖股票的
是
你有一些库存
早盘是让你卖股票的
今天例外啦
今天是开低走高
对
但开低走高盘其实不多
嗯
那到了尾盘呢
你是要找机会买股票的
是
尾盘买股票早上卖掉
那这就是隔日冲啦
对
那这隔日冲呢
他们很多都是去看
今天谁最强
他去买很多那隔天呢他就会卖股票那有的人想说那那这样子我就去隔熱衝的股票好嗎也不一定因為有些隔熱衝的股票他都是很強勢的
那你空很強勢的股票
你的期望值是低的
所以呢
你空很強勢的股票
你要記得那個型態
型態很重要
假如每天都跳空一支線漲停
你就不要空了
像最近有一根
有一檔股票
每天都一支線一支線
買不到買不到買不到
分拆過後的那種
分拆過後 對
那個你就不要追了
就是覺得不要追
那你也不要去空它
尤其是漲停沒有打開
你覺得不要空
因為漲停沒打開
你空可能也有漲停
所以空那種
打開了那
那個漏可能有點多
哈哈哈哈
好 所以現在這樣
這個秘技
你只好是買到隔日沖
買到漲停的股票
隔日沖有大買的股票
你要記得 漲停就續爆
我也想要漲停
對啊 就是你今天可能看到7% 8%
盤多看到7% 8%很強
你想說要不要買一下
看格隆會不會進來鎖
可以啊 你就買個8%
停損你可以設個6%
頂多賠2%而已
他假如鎖漲停 恭喜你
留著 漲停就續爆
有漲停我們當然就續爆
那隔天 但是哪來的漲停
隔天要繼續漲停 繼續爆喔
不要賣喔 你不要說賺一根就走 不要喔
有的格衝買的股票
我常看到那種五根漲停 六根漲停
我也想啊
所以這種跟著格衝鎖漲停
漲停就續爆
那假如這檔股票
它已經開始走空頭趨勢了
那什麼叫空頭趨勢呢
就是月線已經下彎了
這種空頭趨勢呢
這種你要記得
漲停的隔天你要賣
我們用幾個案例來看一下
首先來看全新
全新各位看到
前波到一個高點
後面走有點空頭
最近是做一個反彈
那你看這個隔聰
土城永齡
永齡哥就很厲害
買完之後還漲停兩天
所以永齡哥在照山運動的時候
其實他蠻常去玩的
那照山運動
左邊是照山運動
右邊就走下山了
在下山的時候
你看到永寧哥大買的隔天
記得趕快賣股票
他就做得很短了
做得很短了
好 來看下一個
這邊是格衝最近常賺的一些股票
大部分都強勢股
凱基台北 凱基信義 凱基成中
對 代表凱基的這個軟體蠻好的
所以歌中喜歡用
對
歌中其實也會用元大富邦
好
首先來看這個像合金
合金在高點照三頂的左邊
凱基台北
歌中就蠻常玩的
那三頂的右邊也會玩
只是玩的頻率就減低了
那三頂的右邊你看
只要大長紅
它可能就是一個大紅K
大紅K的隔天
這個拉高你要記得賣股票
你看這邊就有一個
很經典的案例
有點變難玩了對不對
變難玩了 對
最近隔衝變難玩了
因為很多股票都已經在走下坡了
好 再來看下一個
像世維航
世維航這看起來是一個造山運動
造山運動持續中
那什麼樣
什麼時候我們才確認不是造山運動
就是月限殺兩次
現在還沒有月限殺兩次的狀況
那造山運動持續中
我們可以看到
這些隔衝分點
像凱基台北
他就會常常每天玩
今天買明天賣
那他這個節奏會讓他怎麼樣
紅K 黑K 紅K 黑K
那你就跟著他節奏玩
你跟著他買了
隔天早上你就先賣
黑K下來你又可以買
每天這樣玩
其實蠻開心的 蠻有趣的
是 難怪很忙
真的很忙
像真點 真點也是一個
已經造山運動完了
造完了 山頂出現
你看山頂出現到現在都沒有
突過錢高了
所以你看山頂出現之後的大買隔天
你都是要賣股票
凱積信義
他們現在也是有小小的買賣
小小買賣這可能都是賞戶了
那像他們這種大戶一買就是500張
因為500張金額才夠
這個玩起來才有意思
好 現在看這個
連閻光也是最近蠻強的
凱積信義
連光最近也是有這個
隔衝的現象
是
好
那最後呢
還有利基電
利基電算是這個已經
這個山頂有點出現了
所以最近呢
最近這種大滿的隔天
你還是賣比較好
是
好
那最後呢是這義行
又是航運
對
又回到航運
義行看起來是
他不是真的航運
剛開始的
不是真的航運
但是
他可能有別的提案
因為他股價太低了
他之前在高檔26塊
董事長拼聖報早上
聖報到沒有股票了
對 現在又變成低檔
最近跟著航運稍微起來一點
所以現在看起來的話
大家又回頭集合在航運股的狀態
真的還蠻明顯
那會從AI跑到航運嗎
還是兩邊都會有人做
兩邊都會有人做 就輪流做
AI休息買航運 航運休息買AI
因為他們錢也不夠
也叫交歌啦
那前一波這樣下殺的時候
你有聽到哪一些主力分店
有比較受傷嗎
有聽到一些少年股層受傷
就是很喜歡追強勢股的
那後面假如有些點位沒跑掉的話
捨不得停損就被人家砍掉了
因為他們很多都開槓桿的
所以江海是老的啦
對
是吧
沒錯
這些老分點都很大
應該不是說我吧
哥是小哥永遠的小哥
大家好
今天很謝謝小哥幫我們解密了很多主力大戶
而且很多都是熟面孔
真的叫做經得起小哥的考驗
在達人秀
收視率這麼高的節目
然後大家也都知道了
結果他們就不換就是不換
照做給你們
對啊
我做窗戶你買得起嗎
你跟得起吗
你跟啊这样